le pénible c'est un espace
d'expérimentation de tests qu'on a voulu
ouvrir à tout le monde dans un nouveau
lieu du proto qui est à 7 terrasses qui
a juste à côté de l'yvette et on s'est
dit qu'on voulait pouvoir permettre à
tout le monde de pratiquer le végétal
que ce soit pour des start up que ça
pour des habitants des étudiants ou des
chercheurs de brasser toutes ces
communautés là autour du véritable son
histoire date un petit peu parce que
c'est un peu plus d'un an en décembre
2014 ou en fait il ya un groupe de
designers d'architectes et d'innovateurs
assez large qui sont venus avec l'idée
un peu folle de se dire comment est ce
qu'on pourrait transformer le campus à
travers l'agriculture urbaine avec bien
sûr ce contexte de paris saclay qui est
un territoire avec beaucoup
d'agriculture et de nature et en même
temps des scientifiques et la ville
évidemment qui apparaît et ça c'est un
peu les trois piliers on pourrait dire
de l'agriculture urbaine et donc c'est à
dire comment est ce qu'on pourrait faire
ça c'était une séance de design fiction
comme et appelle sa c2 projection dans
l'avenir de ce qui pourrait être
possible
petit à petit on a construit une
démarche sur cette question de à des
cultures urbaines sur le campus et en
juin 2000 2015 donald sicotte et
mathilde briançon nous rejoindre dans
l'équipe du projet pour pour le soutenir
et le mettre en place et en décembre
pour le quatrième atelier de
préfiguration on a fait un peu plus
grand que d'habitude en évitant une
dizaine d'acteurs de l'agriculture
urbaine qu'elle soit locale ou qu'elles
soient en dehors du territoire pour
expliquer ce que c'est convaincre par la
démonstration de ce que eux mêmes font
tous les jours
et puis aussi avoir une activité de peu
d'autocritique on pourrait dire à quoi
ça sert à quoi ça sert moins et on passe
à celui notamment avec le reste
hungry minable appareils saclay où
l'agriculture urbaine apparaissent la
clé on peut se demander pourquoi moi je
pense qu'il ya au moins deux raisons à
cela d'une part c'est de pouvoir
s'approprier la ville d'hakkari culture
et la nature donc rendre la ville peut
être un peu plus belle un peu moins
grise ça a sûrement à ça on peut le
faire donc c'est un premier message vers
les habitants les acteurs de la ville de
prendre part à cette activité eux mêmes
l'autre aspect c'est le un peu comme les
fab lab ont démocratisé la technologie
est ce qu'on peut démocratiser
l'agriculture en tout cas faire en sorte
qu'on cultive soi même ce qui nous fait
plaisir ce que dit ce qui ne semble bon
pour nous à ce sera peut-être pas dans
les quantités suffisantes mais au moins
c'est une pratique qu'on peut faire soi
même et ça c'est quelque chose qui est
important